en 5 años cristian ha vuelto muy pocas
veces a este barrio cercano a las
instituciones europeas con el tiempo las
marcas de quemaduras apenas son visibles
en su rostro pero el recuerdo sigue ahí
el 22 de marzo de 2016
cristian estaba a cuatro metros del
atacante que se inmoló en el metro cerca
a esta estación
todavía hoy despierta muchos
sentimientos cuando el metro se cerró y
se puso en marcha se produjo la
explosión de explosión y el juicio no
está previsto para antes de septiembre
de 2022 sin embargo christian ya se está
preparando se tomará unos días libres
para seguir esta audiencia
extraordinaria que debería durar entre
seis y nueve meses
como queremos entender como los
terroristas pasaron de la radicalización
a la acción
a la chs la comprensión se ha convertido
casi en una obsesión para philippe en
preparación para el juicio esta víctima
incluso tomó cursos legales en ese
momento mi vida está en suspenso y
realmente estoy esperando esta prueba
para poder seguir adelante es
prácticamente el único objetivo en mi
vida en este momento el proceso es
difícil para las víctimas sobre todo
porque desde el atentado se sienten
agraviados por el estado
es sumamente complejo para las víctimas
tener una compensación efectiva están
deambulando entre el fondo de asistencia
las compañías de seguros los distintos
organismos que intervienen y realmente
es muy injusto a diferencia de francia
donde los casos de terrorismo son
juzgados por magistrados profesionales
bélgica recurre a un clásico tribunal de
lo penal el fiscal federal ha pedido en
repetidas ocasiones la destitución del
jurado popular para juicios tan grandes
entre tanto la fecha precisa de este
histórico proceso debería conocerse en
junio